nevada's eviction moratorium is
expiring but do residents have any
protection i spoke with attorney eric
palacios earlier today for the answers
eric thank you for joining us so the
question is is the
eviction moratorium being extended
a great question the answer is it is not
being extended
but for most tenants it really doesn't
matter there's been a federal mandate
that can stop evictions up until the end
of december of this year
okay so is this is this an automatic
thing that just happens for everyone
a great question the nevada moratorium
was
automatic if you're behind on rent you
could not be evicted
but the federal one uh you need to fill
out some forms you need to go on the cdc
uh website and there's a two page form
that you have to fill out
and attest that you are in dire
need of this assistance and then you can
get
uh protected until the end of december
so so what should tenants do then if
they're facing eviction
do what you say right there and go fill
out these forms or any other steps they
need to take if someone's watching right
now facing addiction
a great first step is talk to your
landlord we see that most issues happen
due to lack of communication
the tenant is scared he doesn't answer
the phone he doesn't return
uh letters or messages doesn't answer
the door
so then the landlord doesn't know what's
going on
he also gets scared and tries to start
the process to a victim
if both sides just can be open to
communication explain
their financial situation what their
goals and what they can do
uh financially to pay partial rent or
when they can start getting caught up
that goes a long way to make things uh
resolve in a better way so you're not
facing eviction
so this is not a hit in the same kind of
incident if you get a notice or
something you need to take some kind of
action immediately
that's it and i most of the people that
we're talking to are
folks that did just that they didn't
return calls they didn't answer messages
they didn't open the door
just out of fear but this caused them
to be in a war situation now uh
defending uh an eviction procedure
and if someone is is facing eviction
procedure you guys can help them
uh we can't yeah they can give us a call
and we can guide them what steps they
need to take and
we can help them out as well giving us
the latest and updated information thank
you so much buddy
thanks for having me we'll talk to you
later for more information give eric
palacios and associates a call at
four 702-444-7 seven seven seven you can
also visit their website at
ericpalacioslaw.com and we